hallo mein Name ist Luca und herzlich
willkommen meine Damen und Herren heute
zur mittlerweile schon dritten Episode
von
Lukas Monday
mit Luca ich sitze hier heute meine
Damen und Herren wir bereits sehen könnt
nicht alleine sondern mit Sandra ich
habe ihr selbstverständlich wie ihr seht
wieder meine mobile Mondays mit Luca
Brille aufgezogen habe Sandra dann auch
eine Brille gegeben weil ich dachte das
passt einfach zu dieser Serie die
unterstützt wird von Google Play im
Rahmen der Playon Kampagne also danke
schön Google Play dass ihr das heutige
Video wieder tatkräftig unterstützt und
wir zocken auch selbstverständlich
wieder ein Spiel und zwar heute zusammen
Stadt Land Fluss wir spielen nun jeder
drei Runden Stadt Land Fluss also
insgesamt sechs Runden und in jeder
Runde haben wir vermutlich einen anderen
Buchstaben also wir treten nicht
gegeneinander an mit dem gleichen
Buchstaben sondern jeder kriegt zufällig
einen Buchstaben und dann gucken wir am
Ende gewonnen hat
genau ich würde sagen ich fange an mit
der ersten Runde und zwar seht ihr hier
schon meine Kategorien zugelost etwas
rote Sportarten Sprachen statthauptstadt
und typisch deutsch er möchte einfach
mal auf Spiel starten und jetzt darf ich
das Rad drehen und dementsprechend
welcher Buchstabe rauskommt der ich sehe
durch die Brille gar nichts
oh mein Gott und wie soll ich das jetzt
okay vielleicht spielen wir es dann
beide nur mit dieser Brille also ich
drehe nun das Rad meine lieben Freunde
mein Buchstabe ist der Buchstabe oh
glaube ich los geht's meine Damen und
Herren drei zwei eins und jetzt ist es
auf Zeit etwas Rotes mit O
oh mein Gott
ich mache erstmal weiter mit der
nächsten Sache Sportart mit O
ich kenne mich mit Sport eh nicht so gut
aus alles klar Olympia eigentlich ich
habe keine Ahnung im Sprache mit O
oh mein Gott ich steh komplett auf dem
Schlauch Österreich
staatshauptstädte mit O
hä welches Land
ey wenn ich gleich auch so aber
ich habe keine Ahnung
typisch deutsch was ist denn typisch
deutsch mit oh was ist denn
wann läuft deine Zeit
eine Sekunde jetzt vorbei
ich habe nur Auto
[Musik]
ich habe eineinhalb von fünf Sternen
weil österreichisch das habe ich einen
halben Punkt für bekommen also du drehst
jetzt das Rad und kriegst ein Buchstaben
und äh dann gucken wir ob du mehr als
einer genau
hi Luca aus dem Schnitt hier erstmal
sorry für meine kaputte Stimme und für
mein Aussehen hier allerdings bin ich
komplett erkältet das soll mich
allerdings nicht davon abhalten hier
diesen kurzen Video ein Spieler hier für
euch zu drehen und zwar wollte ich euch
das ganze Spiel statt land fluss doch
mal richtig erklären und zwar geht's bei
der App eigentlich nicht darum dass man
nebeneinander sitzt und an dem gleichen
Handy äh die Stadt Land Fluss Kategorien
eine richtig beantwortet mit dem
Buchstaben sondern normalerweise spielt
man das ganze Spiel online gegen
irgendwelche zufälligen Gegner oder
gegen irgendwelche Freunde von einem die
irgendwo anders sitzen ähm sah noch
nicht dachten allerdings dass es
vielleicht ein bisschen lustiger ist
wenn wir zusammen vor der Kamera sitzen
deswegen haben wir es am gleichen
Endgerät gespielt und deswegen haben wir
auch unterschiedliche Buchstaben was
auch immer für das Video ein bisschen
sinnvoller ist und deswegen ist es halt
nicht so dass wir zu Beginn jeder Runde
einzeln drehen weil normalerweise spielt
man halt einzelne Spieler immer das
heißt jetzt glaube ich alles ein
bisschen kompliziert an aber ich wollte
euch nur ganz kurz sagen was der Grund
dafür ist dass Sandra jetzt
beispielsweise nicht drehen musste
allerdings sind Sandras Kategorien jetzt
Käsesorten ich verlor meine berühmte
Marken berühmte klassische Musik und
Dinge die man nicht berühren darf viel
Spaß jetzt mit Sandras Runde besonders
Buchstabe ist z meine Damen und Herren
und äh was heißt was ist das Essen
Z7 oh mein Gott der direkt den ersten
Punkt ey man sieht ja gar nichts durch
diese Brille ich sehe was ich sage Alter
warte
Alter Alter Klasse stimmt Musiker
Komponente was erzählen
Dinge die man nicht berühren sollte
kannst du auch nehmen drei drei junge
Ehre ich habe dich so sehr junge ja mann
komplett auseinander genommen
wisst ihr okay ich bin einfach der King
nein danke übrigens auch an Google dass
sie mir dafür das neue Google Pixel
zugesendet haben auf dem ihr die Sachen
gerade zocken allerdings ich möchte
jetzt sagen ich mache weiter mit meiner
Runde in der nächsten Runde sind meine
Kategorien jetzt mein Drache ist Verben
Werkzeuge Tiere und deutsche
TV-Moderatorin eben manchmal bekommt man
einfach so direkt ein Buchstaben oder
manchmal darf man auch selbst drehen
aber bei dir was aber relativ gut ich
habe Buchstabe e okay es easy e ist safe
easy okay los geht's mein Drache ist
[Musik]
ekelhaft
ekelhaft mein Drache ist ekelhaft Verben
mit eh Essen Werkzeuge mit ehm
Werkzeuge mit eh
in
Elektrorasierer danke für den Tipp
Digger Tiere Esel und deutsche
TV-Moderatorin
ich kenne keinen einzigen TV Frank
Elstner oh mein Gott Alter Sandra oh
mein Gott wenn ich fünf Punkte habe kein
alter ich flippe im Quadrat vier
Elektrorasierer ist kein Werkzeug vier
Punkte dicker was geht ab Alter
Kategorien für die nächste Runde sind
Wörter mit vier Buchstaben Verben
berühmte Marken ein Wort das X enthält
und Bands und Solokünstler bzw
Künstlerin okay bei Sandra geht's wieder
direkt
vier Buchstaben
[Musik]
ja die Ex-Freundin kannst du machen ja
Eminem fertig oh mein Gott junge wenn
du mich besiegt hast jetzt obwohl ich 4
hatte
[Musik]
junge ich ziehe dich ab der ist graue
vier Punkte und dachte ich wäre krank
mit dabei du hast fünf ich habe doch
gesagt Digger ich bin die Schloss aus
ganz Deutschland ich bin der Tornado
durch ganz Deutschland
letzte Runde meine Damen und Herren ich
bekomme hier wieder Kategorien
Zugriff weil bei uns abwechselnd ist
einfach dass ich das zugelost bekomme
und du den Buchstaben direkt bekommst
aber bisher hattest du immer Glück was
habe ich VV oh mein Gott ey was ja Benz
und Solokünstler mit V muss ich jetzt
auch machen
[Musik]
Kleidungsstücke mit V äh nehme ich
einfach
[Musik]
es gibt nichts mehr vor es gibt nichts
mit V oder Werkzeuge mit V was was soll
Vogel Vogel
warum helfe ich dir eigentlich
eigentlich ein bisschen Musikgenres mit
V Vogelgesang
berühmte Marken
Volvo ich hätte wohler genommen warte
die machen Bad Armaturen und so weiter
und so fort ich habe einen Punkt für
Volvo
jetzt bin ich dran und ich werde wieder
die fünf Punkte holen meiner vorigen
Runde meine fünf Kategorien ja ausgelost
und angezeigt wurden habe ich da jetzt
nicht noch mal so ein Spieler hier
aufgenommen allerdings hier für Sandra
noch mal ihre Kategorien jetzt in dieser
Runde Kleidungsstücke Körperteile Bands
und Solokünstler bzw Künstlerin
staatshauptstädte und Länder also viel
Spaß jetzt bei Sandras letzten Runde
mein Wort Buchstabe
Jacke oh mein Gott
Winterjacke du hast schon gewonnen
im Körperteil mit W
Wirbelsäule
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott ich bin heftig
pranks mit wem solo Künstler Alter
gebe ich einfach gezählt davor
Wale
ich dachte du sagst Wien
mit a geschrieben Washington mir gibt
wie nein gib nie nein das ist besser
Weißrussland
weißweiß-rost Russland das Ende hinter
das Ende hinter Wien nein nein nein nein
zurück an okay fertig
zusammen gemacht
Alter Alter
Punkt weiter
ihre junge ja meine Damen und Herren
sama geben erstmal meine Brille zurück
hier Danke Schön ja meine Damen und
Herren das war das heutige mobile Mann
jetzt mit Luca Video ich habe mir
gedacht das passt natürlich super wenn
wir Stadt Land Fluss spielen das jetzt
zusammen mit meiner
Lieblingsstelle ja Lieblingsmenschen auf
der Welt
wenn euch das heutige Video gefallen hat
dann lasst unbedingt einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da ähm danke auch
noch mal an der Stelle an Google Play
dass sie im Rahmen der Player und
Kampagne das Video heute unterstützt
haben da können wir wirklich nochmal
klatschen
auf jeden Fall die heutige Challenge
gewonnen und ihr seht gerade auch schon
über Sandras Gesicht das heutige outro
eingeblendet dass sie mich ein Icon von
dem Spiel Stadt Land Fluss da könnt ihr
einfach draufklicken und euch das Spiel
runterladen könnt ihr selbst mal zocken
sagen wie weit ihr so kommt mit dem
Buchstaben jetzt auch ein anderes Video
verlinkt das ist nämlich das letzte
Video von mal bei meiner ist mit Luca
und schreibt in die Kommentare wer
gewinnt tschüss die wer gewinnt du hast
gewonnen
ja aber die spielt das doch auch da
könnt ihr darauf schreiben wer gewinnt
schreibt in die Kommentare wer bei euch
gewinnt